we're talking about dating at different
ages and our next question comes from
sarah
sarah what's your question hi drew
hi damona i'm so excited to be here um
so basically i was married for 15 years
and i'm recently divorced
i'm a busy mom i was on the apps but i
got a lot of young guys trying to date
me
and i'm not a cougar it was a total turn
off for me
i have lots of energy i love trying new
things
but dating just hasn't been a priority
but
i'm definitely ready now i know the big
thing right now are dating apps but
it's not really my thing my question is
even during this crazy time of the
pandemic
how can i meet someone without going
online
okay i'm going to jump in because i
think i know what drew's going to say
but i want to let you know that online
dating
is where it's at and 40 of people
are meeting their matches on dating apps
right now so
it's really the biggest party in town
and i want you to be at the biggest
and best party especially as a mom of
two
i'm also a mom of two we're busy ladies
sarah we don't have a lot of
time to date you can't be out here
running the streets trying to find a man
it's time efficient and you can really
be
searching while you're in the privacy of
your own home while your kids are asleep
line up those dates it's a great way to
find
a match and it's especially a great way
for for a single mom to find love in
today's world i would say
your love lesson is to develop a growth
mindset you might even talk to your kids
about that
just it's something that's new you
haven't gotten good at it yet and i
really look at dating especially online
dating
as a learned set of skills so just
because it's foreign doesn't mean you
can't do it you just say
i'm not into online dating yet but stay
open to the possibility that you could
find love there and damona
you said something like there is a 40
success rate on online dating
yeah and i would bet even with the
pandemic it's going to go up drew
yeah exactly it's like you know it just
got a lot
harder to meet people out and about
because of 2020 and the pandemic so
maybe just try to have a different
mindset
i'm trying it on i talked to this woman
last week
she's coming on the show she's divorced
with two kids too and she's about to go
on our first date and we had this like
45 minute long conversation and i had
two aha moments from it i'm really
excited to talk about on the show
try putting all of your baggage on top
of a car and
sending that car off a cliff get on that
dating app and just
try anew i'll do it all right
forward good and i wish you the best of
luck i really do
thank you okay our next question is from
chris
he's 30. he's in his 30s oh hi chris
hi how are you hi okay what's your
dating question
yeah so first off i'm a huge fan of drew
and damona
yay so essentially uh i've been
practicing
mindful dating i've been journaling i've
been visio boarding
visualizing my future partner but
essentially how do i set up my profile
to attract women my age that are looking
to settle down
essentially well first of all
thanks chris i can tell if you are
already listening to the dates and maids
podcast you know my advice
you have all the pieces we just have to
put them together
in the right order so when i hear that
question i think we either have
a profile problem or we have a pool
problem
if it's a profile problem it means
you're not putting out what you think
you're saying into the world
so if you want something serious you
need to present yourself in a serious
way
so get rid of any beach shots or
shirtless bathroom selfies
we want to look like you do right now
like uh like a partner would right
and then if it's a pool problem you
might not be on the right app some
apps have a really low barrier for entry
like if it's free
if you can just pick a couple pictures
and suddenly you're
on the dating app and you you see that
there is a variety there there are
a whole range of of reasons that people
are on the app you might want to try an
app
that requires a little bit more effort
that has a little bit more information
so that you can really sort through
and filter your dates appropriately i
have to say
demona you are spot on and i'm
i think older than you and obviously
looking for someone my age or a little
older
but i am so turned off for any
like seriousness with all the beach
shots and the
how is everyone a photographer now and
you're posing with someone else's kid
and your and your dog it's like
it's literally it is cookie cutter and
it does send out a message of like
this isn't serious i'm here to just date
and be frivolous
i think you're so right demona tell a
picture
tell a story through your pictures show
through your pictures what you're
looking for
a vision a visual says a lot
absolutely yeah well thank you guys
demona
i love you and um chris and sarah
and michelle this was so much fun thank
you for doing us
with this uh this with us today i can't
talk
and uh we'd love to check in with you
and see how it's going thank you demona
[Music]